muy buenos días pues efectivamente ahora
pues todos los ojos el foco de todo lo
que ocurra con la reina isabel o en todo
caso con el féretro de la reina isabel
es aquí en edimburgo y me encuentro a
las afueras de la capital escocesa y
después hay un gran dispositivo de
seguridad la mayoría de las arterias
principales de la ciudad todas ya están
cerradas la mayoría de las calles del
casco histórico que son calles más bien
angostas todo esto ha sido cerrado desde
muy temprano el día de hoy y por
supuesto para la policía incluso desde
el día viernes ya venía estudiando muy
bien el programa para saber exactamente
qué calles debía cerrar cuántos
efectivos debían atenerse saben que hay
estuvo elsa lo largo de todo el camino
del royal mal por donde pasará cuando
llegue al hamburgo esta tarde sobre las
un poco después de las cuatro de la
tarde -hora local- hasta que llegue a él
hasta el palacio de holyrood esto es
acerca de enfrente en realidad del
parlamento escocés y lo cierto es que
pues de todas las actividades en
realidad están muy tranquilas muy
calmadas el día de hoy en edimburgo
se ha cerrado la mayoría de las
atracciones turísticas por unos 34 días
en la ciudad y pues la gente está
pidiendo a todos los residentes e
incluso personas que han venido hasta el
burgo para dar el último adiós a la
reina pues de que lleguen hasta muy
temprano para encontrar un buen puesto y
que sobre todo eviten a toda costa
utilizar a sus automóviles así que como
verán pues todo un dispositivo bastante
bastante elaborado bastante detallado
para que nada falle y sobre todo pues se
pueda manejar el gran volumen de
personas que se esperan a partir del día
de hoy aquí en edimburgo natalidad nos
decías que irá al palacio de holyrood
cuánto tiempo permanecerá así que se
prevé en este sentido
bueno va a llegar allí al palacio de
hollywood y va a estar en la sala del
trono como escuchamos en el informe hace
un momento la idea también de que esté
allí en esa sala es hacer lo que ya
estuvo haciendo en el mejor dicho lo que
se planeó también en balmoral la idea es
que todo el personal de este palacio
pues se pueda también darle un último
adiós a la reina así que el féretro
estará allí hasta la tarde de mañana ya
cuando sea el rey carlos tercero la
reina con suerte que lleguen sobre las
dos y media de la tarde a edimburgo y
pues comience también toda esta
procesión que será bastante larga ese
camino largo el arroyo del mal que es un
poquito más de una milla en realidad que
de esta calle principal de la casco
antiguo de hambruna bellísima calle
además y pues justamente será toda esa
procesión desde hollywood hasta hasta la
catedral de assen dios hoy lo que se
espera más allá de la llegada a
hollywood es también la primera ministra
de escocia nicola sturgeon y los
principales líderes políticos
escocia pese a que vayan también a
hollywood para dar un último adiós a la
reina eso es lo que se tiene previsto en
todo caso así que digamos que el féretro
estará hasta la tarde de este el próximo
lunes en hollywood natalia hubo varias
versiones no hay trascendidos respecto
de la manera en que sería trasladado el
féretro de la reina isabel el segunda en
qué tipo de vehículo porque falleció en
escocia no y el protocolo es diferente
no si fallecía en escocia o si lo hacía
por ejemplo en londres que se sabe
entonces al respecto como es
específicamente ese traslado en qué tipo
de vehículo por ejemplo
exactamente santiago pues esta es la
operación unicornio así es como la que
se llama cómo se llama lo que se tenía
planeado en caso de que ella falleciera
aquí en escocia que va a combinarse con
la operación london bridge por ahora
pues lo que se sabe es que serán seis
guardas los que trasladarán desde la
sala de danza de balmoral hasta el
vehículo que la va a transportar pues
éste el féretro de la reina un féretro
que he hecho además en madera de roble y
luego será un digamos digamos un viaje
que irá bastante lento por más de doce
en pequeñas poblaciones ahí del
aberdeen a estar la idea es que de
alguna manera puesto que se ha previsto
es que sea un paso por oro digamos por
todos esos lugares que ella tanto amaba
son lugares de muchísimos bosques muchos
bosques de pinos es muy verde toda esta
región un poco salvaje y también de
muchísimas montañas así lo que se tiene
es por ejemplo el primer lugar el primer
pueblito por donde ella va a pasar esa
balacera justamente estuvimos allí el
día de ayer y los locales nos decían qué
a ellos pues en realidad no se trata de
la reina que conocían bien a la familia
real porque tenían a pues la costumbre o
tienen la costumbre de venir a hacer
algunas compras en especial en la
carnicería y que en realidad para ellos
no se trata de la familia real sino que
lo ve nomás como cualquier persona
cualquier residente de esa comunidad así
que es un poco como ser han perdido uno
de ellos la idea entonces es que todo
este cortejo fúnebre va a pasar de
manera bastante lenta ya desde el día de
ayer habían ha previsto es cerrar las
calles principales de estas poblaciones
habían puesto incluso ya iconos para
mostrar por donde debía circular el
tránsito con muchísimas restricciones
también para que los carros se pudieran
pues estar estacionados a lo largo de
las calles así que eso es lo que se
tiene previsto a lo largo pues de éstas
seis horas que va a durar el viaje
normalmente nosotros que hicimos ese
recorrido el día de ayer se hacen unas
más o menos tres horas así que aquí será
el doble de tiempo porque va a tomar
pues todo ese tiempo para que la gente
pueda despedirse y para quienes vayan
siguiendo la transmisión en algún
momento ustedes ver el mar del norte qué
es lo que ustedes ven a mis espaldas y
un poquito lejos está allí en el queen's
a felix brych con strike rating que es
uno de los puentes más grandes del mundo
y por ahí pasará el cortejo y ya cuando
ella esté sobre ese puente sabremos que
está próxima a llegar a edimburgo